you broke the stage it was great
girl named tom delivered such a powerful
performance on the voice they actually
broke the stage well kinda live tv you
did so well you broke something
on monday during night one of the season
21 finale the sibling trio took the
stage for a performance of the
foundation's baby now that i found you
and no surprise here it was pitch
perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
but when they stepped down to receive
the coach's feedback some other kind of
feedback was happening on stage that was
so so stunning as always there's a sound
behind you that's really jarring and
it's fun to try to ignore you broke the
stage it was great
gorgeous it's a rogue light of some sort
kelly live tv you did so well you broke
something
girl named tom has been a front-runner
since their four-chair turn to start the
season
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and on night two of the finale the band
will perform with their coach kelly
clarkson before finding out if they'll
be the first trio to win the voice in
the show's 21 season run that's the
thing about the voice that i love most
is you find these artists that a lot of
people can sing but you find those gems
that really know how to move you
and one thing's for sure kelly is moved
by a girl named tom
i'm so proud to say that you're on my
team it's just such a special thing for
me you're such a great group and you
have such a great bond i was so excited
in rehearsals and i know i look like
such a goober fan when e.t recently
asked kelly and her fellow coaches john
legend ariana grande and blake shelton
who has the biggest reactions to the
performances on the voice the answer was
unanimous
oh kelly kelly
what
have you seen her gifts have you seen
her gifts
i don't know if that's a good thing
to be the gift girl um no but i you're
expressive i am expressive i am
passionate i like to say um i get very
excited
um
yeah i would probably say me
but that's a beautiful thing but one
singer who had all the coaches in their
fields monday night team blake singer
wendy moton
[Music]
the 56-year-old nashville-based singer
has been a standout all season but her
final performance of over the rainbow
brought the house down and had the
coaches on their feet i just don't think
i've ever seen anyone with a gift like
you have your voice is just so
flawless and perfect and then you just
stand there and do it with such
nonchalance and it's just stunning that
you're able to do what you're able to do
ladies and gentlemen this is
when i say world-class
talent
i'm talking about
this may never happen again
blake has made it no secret that he's
one of her biggest fans after landing
wendy's four-chair turn during her blind
audition
[Music]
in fact he's repeatedly said she's the
most deserving singer he's ever coached
i've been doing this show for 21 seasons
now as a coach
and there is nobody that i want this
more
for
ever than you
you you deserve this
[Music]
you